[Applauso]
Guardate Quel puntino lo vedete
in fondo
vi aiuto io
Eccolo sapete cos'è
ve lo dico io è la Terra è qui siamo noi
su quel piccolo granellino azzurro ogni
persona che amate ogni persona che
conoscete ogni persona anche solo di cui
avete sentito parlare ogni essere umano
che sia mai esistito ha vissuto la
propria vita
così carosegan nel 1990 commentava
questa foto una foto che ci giunge da
più di 6 miliardi di chilometri di
distanza e che avrebbe cambiato per
sempre la nostra percezione di chi siamo
nello spazio ma anche nel tempo
dall'inizio della ricerca spaziale
abbiamo identificato più di 5.000
esopianeti che sono tutti quei pianeti
che si trovano fuori dal nostro sistema
solare L'obiettivo era quello di trovare
un pianeta che assomigliasse al nostro e
abbiamo scoperto un sacco di cose
interessanti alcune di questi pianeti
hanno persino acqua liquida sulla loro
superficie certo Questo non significa
che siano abitabili per noi e se anche
lo fossero non potremmo mai raggiungerli
perché le nostre tecnologie non ce lo
permettono Quindi questa foto ci ricorda
che la Terra è unica una gemma rara
nell'universo e quindi Sorge spontanea
la domanda perché allora andiamo nello
spazio perché investire tempo soldi e
risorse in qualcosa che non sappiamo se
esiste e se anche esistesse non potremo
mai raggiungere
Beh se c'è una risposta a questa domanda
forse dovrei saperla io D'altronde ho
studiato ingegneria aerospaziale ho
preso un master in aerodinamica e
sistemi di propulsione pubblicato
diverse ricerche persino collaborato ad
un progetto con la NASA nonché servizio
fare tutte queste cose per arrivare una
risposta però volevo fare le cose fatte
bene però in tutto questo tempo non mi
sono mai soffermato veramente a pensare
a questa domanda forse perché nella mia
testa la risposta era scontata era ovvia
e in qualche modo pensavo che dovesse
essere Ovvio anche per gli altri
Ovviamente non è così e me ne sono
accorto quando ho cominciato a
raccontare lo spazio a un certo punto ho
deciso di cominciare a postare dei video
su Instagram YouTube Cercando di
raccontare lo spazio e la scienza in una
maniera un pochino più accessibile più
semplice e mi sono reso conto in questo
frangente che ci sono un sacco di
persone che sono scettiche riguardo
all'esplorazione spaziale Anzi sono
sicuro che fra di voi sicuramente c'è
qualcuno che la pensa allo stesso modo
e quindi stasera sono qua con voi per
cercare di rispondere insieme a voi a
questa domanda perché andiamo nello
spazio e nel farlo voglio portare alla
vostra attenzione 3 commenti 3 obiezioni
Se vogliamo che sono quelle che mi
vengono fatte più spesso sotto i miei
video sui social e queste tre obiezioni
questi tre commenti hanno a che fare con
gli spaghetti
Il brindisi di Capodanno e la bomba
atomica non vi preoccupate avrà tutto un
senso alla fine promesso la prima
domanda Forse quella più frequente
perché dobbiamo spendere soldi per
andare nello spazio anziché spenderli
per risolvere i nostri problemi qua
sulla terra perché in effetti andare
nello spazio ci costa parecchio Nel 2020
la NASA da sola speso 23 miliardi di
dollari certo non ci viene detto che in
realtà questo è solo una piccolissima
fetta del budget federale statunitense
non ci viene neanche detto che la NASA
genera molti più soldi di quelli che
spende grazie alle sue ricerche spaziali
e non ci viene neanche detto che al
momento fornisce più di 300 mila posti
di lavoro in tutto il mondo ma questa è
la NASA al mondo non c'è solo NASA di
fatto Ad oggi ci sono nel pianeta più di
10.000 aziende aerospaziali 200 delle
quali si trovano in Italia Quindi anche
da italiani
lo spazio ci tocca da vicino e più che
noi possiamo dire che tocca il nostro
portafogli In effetti ognuno di voi con
le proprie tasse contribuisce ogni anno
a finanziare la ricerca spaziale so che
molti di voi non sono contenti di
scoprire questa cosa
e sarete ancora meno contenti quando fra
un attimo vi dirò quanto ognuno di voi
spende all'anno per finanziare lo spazio
siete pronti
16 euro
se andate a Riccione un piatto di
spaghetti allo scoglio vi costa di più
per farvi un altro paragone ogni anno
ognuno di voi per le spese militari la
difesa spende circa 433
quindi forse lo spazio non costa poi
così tanto come Vogliono farci credere
però è comunque vero che ci sono un
sacco di problemi sul nostro pianeta che
forse meriterebbero la nostra attenzione
per pensarne uno
la fame nel mondo
ad oggi una persona su 10 sul pianeta è
Malta e 9 milioni di persone ogni anno
muoiono per malattie collegate alla
malnutrizione quello che non vediamo
però è che in realtà lo spazio ci aiuta
a combattere queste piaghe e lo fa in
particolare grazie a un gigantesco
laboratorio grande come un campo da
calcio che si trova a 400 chilometri
sopra le nostre teste sto parlando della
Stazione Spaziale internazionale
all'interno di questa stazione gli
astronauti eseguono un sacco di
esperimenti e cercano di scoprire nuove
tecnologie per migliorare ogni giorno la
nostra vita sulla terra e ovviamente
come sospettate probabilmente nello
spazio non c'è acqua
e portare continuamente acqua sulla
stazione costerebbe tantissimo Quindi a
un certo punto gli astronauti hanno
dovuto ingegnarsi e riciclare l'acqua
che era già presente sulla stazione
Difatti ad oggi il 90 per cento quindi
quasi tutta l'acqua che è presente sulla
stazione viene riciclata e poi
riutilizzata quindi sì se ve lo state
chiedendo in questa foto Samantha
cristoforetti molto probabilmente sta
bevendo la propria pipì
e anche questo non volevate saperlo
ovviamente nello spazio non c'è neanche
cibo ovviamente
Però stiamo cercando di trovare dei
metodi per coltivare e produrre cibo in
assenza di gravità e stiamo Ottenendo
dei risultati niente male Guardate
queste piantine di peperoncino che in
questo momento sono sulla stazione
Quindi tutte queste tecnologie queste
nuove scoperte ci permettono oggi di
portare acqua pulita anche nelle zone
più remote del mondo e di riciclare
quell'acqua una volta utilizzata Non
solo ma capire come coltivare in
ambiente estremo ci permette di rendere
coltivabili tutte quelle zone del mondo
che non potrebbero essere adibite a
coltivazione poi ci sono un sacco di
altri utilizzi per le tecnologie
spaziali pensiamo ai pannelli solari che
sono stati inventati per dare energia
elettrica alle nostre navicelle spaziali
che oggi ci forniscono energia pulita
pensiamo alle TAC alle radiografie che
erano delle tecnologie che nello spazio
si utilizzavano per elaborare le
immagini spaziali e che oggi ci
permettono di vedere e diagnosticare
meglio in ambito medico
Quindi quando mi viene chiesto perché
dobbiamo investire dei soldi in ambito
spaziale anziché investirli per
migliorare quello che abbiamo qua sulla
terra la risposta è che è proprio quello
che stiamo facendo se proprio grazie
alle tecnologie spaziali possiamo
combattere piaghe come la fame la sete
nel mondo e che senza le tecnologie
spaziali queste difficoltà sarebbero
molto molto molto più complesse da
combattere
poi c'è la seconda
obiezione secondo commento che leggo più
spesso soprattutto quando parlo di Marte
di andare su Marte colonizzare
eventualmente Marte nel futuro perché
molte persone pensano che dovremmo
concentrarci prima a salvare la terra
anziché pensare di andare su Marte e
cercando di verità in questa frase
perché abbiamo visto all'inizio che la
Terra è una gemma rara e forse dovremmo
salvarla e preservarla
la cosa cambiamento climatico per
esempio certo la terra all'inizio della
sua vita era un pianeta Vulcanico con
temperature oltre i 200 gradi
un'atmosfera che per noi ovviamente
sarebbe irrespirabile e' anche vero che
ha fatto a pugni con quasi tutto il
sistema solare con corpi celesti Anche i
grandi come pianeti quindi mi viene un
po' difficile pensare che un pianeta di
questo tipo abbia bisogno di noi
una sottospecie di scimmie un pochino
più evolute con qualche pelo di meno
D'altronde siamo sulla terra da 300 mila
anni e la Terra di anni ne ha 4 miliardi
e mezzo per farvi un paragone se la vita
dell'universo 13,8 miliardi di anni la
paragonassimo a un anno solare il Big
Bang avverrebbe il primo di gennaio la
terra apparirebbe più o meno l'11 di
settembre l'homo Sapiens sarebbe il suo
ingresso nella storia non prima del 31
dicembre alle 11:59 di sera
un minuto prima di stappare lo spumante
per Capodanno
quindi siamo sulla terra relativamente
da molto poco e in tutto questo tempo la
terra ne ha passate di cotte di crude ha
visto ben cinque estinzioni di massa
causate dai motivi più disparati
cambiamento climatico meteoriti come nel
caso dei dinosauri però c'è una cosa che
accomuna tutti questi eventi che nessuna
di queste estinzioni di massa fu causata
direttamente dalle specie che abitavano
il pianeta Allora non solo ma nessuna di
queste specie avrebbe avuto gli
strumenti per salvarsi dalla propria
estinzione
Ebbene oggi stiamo assistendo alla sesta
estinzione di massa e se avete bisogno
di trovare un responsabile potete
guardarvi intorno perché siamo noi ed è
la prima volta nella storia del pianeta
in cui una specie che abita il pianeta
stesso e responsabile di un estinzione
di Massa
però c'è anche qualche buona notizia
ogni tanto del diamo qualcuna
che grazie alle tecnologie Spaziali in
particolare grazie ai satelliti possiamo
monitorare lo scioglimento dei ghiacciai
le correnti la deforestazione
l'innalzamento delle temperature e agire
in maniera mirata per risolvere il
problema tracciamenti che non potremmo
fare altrimenti in più Grazie sempre
alle tecnologie spaziali Un giorno
potremmo sviluppare le risorse per
abbandonare il pianeta qualora le cose
si mettessero davvero male
quindi in un certo senso grazie alle
tecnologie spaziali noi Un giorno
potremmo diventare la prima specie che
abbia mai abitato il pianeta e che ha le
capacità di salvarsi dalla propria
estinzione causata peraltro per sua
stessa mano eventualmente
perché forse Dobbiamo cominciare a
pensare che siamo noi quelli in pericolo
siamo noi quelli che rischiano
l'estinzione ripeto sempre per mano
nostra peraltro forse siamo noi a
doverci salvare e non la terra
di fatto pensare che la terra abbia
bisogno di noi per salvarsi e oltremodo
egoistico e se ci pensiamo Se domani ci
estinguessimo la Terra
ce la caverebbe benissimo così come
sarei cavata nel passato in situazioni
molto più critiche di quelle in cui si
trova ora
E in ogni caso se anche riuscissimo
davvero come ci piace dire a salvare la
terra a un certo punto per eventi che
sono fuori dal nostro controllo la terra
non sarebbe comunque più abitabile il
che mi riporta e mi collega al terzo
commento che leggo molto spesso secondo
il quale Siccome abbiamo distrutto la
terra con le nostre attività quando si
trasferiremo su Marte o chi per lui
allora distruggeremo anche Esso
so che molti di voi forse la pensano
così e sono d'accordo ma io no
ovviamente perché è vero che nella
nostra storia abbiamo fatto un sacco di
cose terribili commesso un sacco di
errori Però forse questi errori ci hanno
insegnato qualcosa forse gli errori che
stiamo commettendo oggi insegneranno
qualcosa A chi verrà dopo di noi e
allora io mi chiedo Chiedo anche a voi
abbiamo davvero così poca considerazione
di noi stessi da non pensare di poter
essere migliore di così
perché diamo così tanto credito a tutte
le cose sicuramente terribili che
abbiamo fatto ma non pensiamo mai con
positività e speranza alle cose
altrettanto meravigliose che abbiamo
realizzato una su tutte toccare con mano
la superficie di un altro corpo Celeste
e oggi Marte può essere di nuovo quella
grande impresa dell'uomo non solo per la
grandiosità tecnologica dell'impresa in
sé ma per il fatto che Marte è difficile
È pericoloso pieno di sfide di ostacoli
e se davvero vogliamo farcela Allora
tutta l'umanità Ognuno di noi deve
rispondere alla chiamata Ogni agenzia
spaziale ogni governo deve fare la sua
parte Marte potrebbe essere la prima
collaborazione globale della storia nel
passato i popoli si univano per
combattere un nemico comune da
distruggere lo spazio e Marte potrebbero
essere quella cosa che unisce tutta
l'umanità verso un obiettivo comune da
raggiungere
la sopravvivenza
immaginiamo un mondo all'interno del
quale l'essere umano è riuscito a
mettere da parte quell'egoismo quella
arroganza che lo caratterizzano per
capire quello che forse avrebbe dovuto
capire già da tempo che siamo tutti
esseri umani tutti
esseri umani sulla stessa barca
equipaggio di quel piccolo granellino
Celeste che viaggia nel Cosmo attorno
alla sua Stella Ecco Se riuscissimo
davvero a fare questo salto di
consapevolezza e a percepire l'umanità
come una specie unita Allora forse
avremo una possibilità forse avremo una
possibilità di non essere quelli che
arrivano alla festa all'ultimo minuto
avremo un'occasione di non essere stati
solo una breve scintilla su quel piccolo
pianeta in quella Galassia ai confini
dell'universo
e so che è difficile soprattutto di
questi tempi immaginare un'umanità così
con questa consapevolezza però in questo
senso lo spazio può esserci ancora di
aiuto Infatti quando sulla terra non
c'era spazio per altro se non odio e
guerra lo spazio era la nostra Oasi di
pace e collaborazione lo spazio è sempre
stato un precursore e forse oggi può
giocare ancora questo ruolo per noi
e quindi rispondendo alla domanda
iniziale Io penso che sia proprio per
questo che andiamo nello spazio Andiamo
nello spazio per essere migliori Andiamo
nello spazio
per sopravvivere abbastanza lungo da
diventare la versione migliore di noi e
noi potremmo essere i primi a cominciare
questo cambiamento potremmo essere
Ricordati come la generazione spaziale
L'era del Rinascimento dell'esplorazione
spaziale
l'alba di una nuova fase dell'evoluzione
un uomo che viaggia nel Cosmo un essere
umano che è riuscito a elevare il suo
concetto di umanità e forse tutto quello
che facciamo oggi nello spazio lo
facciamo affinché questo uomo che
viaggia fra le stelle un giorno possa
nascere davvero
tanto tempo fa l'universo ha avuto
inizio casualmente e poco tempo dopo
altrettanto casualmente hanno cominciato
a formarsi le prime stelle
all'interno di queste stelle poi hanno
cominciato a costruirsi tutti gli
elementi che oggi compongono l'universo
tutto ciò che ci circonda noi stessi
siamo fatti di elementi che tanto tempo
fa sono stati prodotti all'interno di
una stella Ora io non so se è vero che
siamo veramente solo il frutto di una
fluttuazione cosmica casuale o se invece
c'è un motivo più profondo per
l'esistenza ma una cosa la so
che siamo letteralmente Figli delle
stelle E se c'è una risposta a tutte
queste domande e fra le stelle che
dobbiamo cercarlo Grazie
[Applauso]